yeah the [ __ ] that jay was wearing that
that type of
material for like uh
yeah oh when he came out feels weird
like the bit like the under armour yeah
diesel
some cultures like the way the british
used to when britain basically took over
the world the way you would dress you
would have a you'd have you'd wear a
wool against your skin
back in the day man and then you'd have
bespoke shoes which were leather
and your feet would be like this
crunched into a [ __ ] cone but it was
just
and they wear hats all the time you also
wouldn't sit in comfortable chairs until
the after dinner in the evening the
aristocracy you would sit in a [ __ ]
straight back chair because it was part
of the discipline
we were watching 1883 last night and i
was you know the women are like
full-blown they're in the middle of
texas in the summer and they're
full-blown dress correct there's no
shorts like the guys are in full-blown
like multiple layers all the time
no ac no deodorant yeah
like i grew up i'm old enough i'm old
enough to to have grown up when you had
to dress a certain way in certain
circumstances well it's still that way
now but people lost respect yes carry on
yes but like when people at the airport
and they're wearing like sandals and
sweats pajamas do you have jobs no
respect for yourself pajamas they're
also surrounded by other people like
this isn't a [ __ ]
leisure outlet well that's what's
interesting about it is like you can
trace sort of the way people dress
sometimes with sort of
how society how they are
it
it is like i hate clothes i'll i'll wear
pajamas if i have to but yeah you
wouldn't wear them outside the house to
the airport because i don't know if i
saw you at the airport in like
i don't know like slippers and like yeah
[ __ ] you're like i'd like o'conn's
not doing well right yeah it's lazy even
though you probably are like oh he's but
i would i be like it's a little bit lazy
man when i see that
like i i what do you think of this this
might sound judgmental right but what if
what if um
if you see somebody who's like dressed
really sloppy and you're just you're
going to the supermarket
my guess is my feeling is that's a
reflection of how their mind is at that
moment right so i don't know if that
might
might just be their lifestyle it might
be out there
depending on what you're doing right
that's what i mean yeah but there's some
like billionaires who dress like [ __ ] or
whatever so there's people always give
that example like oh whatever yeah but
what guys insert bill and him like he
where he drives a civic every day yeah
but what got them to the dance like
sometimes they have their their focus
like bill gates was focused only on what
he was doing that he didn't have time to
think about that
that might be different so uh al
madrigal he used to hire people he was a
hirer and he used to fire higher and
fire people
for this company and he would uh he
would walk the people would interview
him he would walk them to their car
to see what every every time to see how
clean the inside of their car was if it
was a dirty car they didn't get the job
it's constantly but it's it's so true no
that's not silly no it's not silly at
all it's not you see you'd be like oh
you're living out of your car they said
now but again unless the guy's like
hustling he's like yeah usually it's
clean man i've been swamped running from
you know every day interview they got
like three kids and [ __ ] then it's a
little you were poor yeah when you were
poor i guarantee your car was clean yeah
yeah i remember yeah your car was clean
it didn't matter because it's like the
least you could do
it's not even that it's just
disappointing yeah you just don't it's
speaking of discipline you had a baby
well i had a baby you know kid got a
dick on him
kid's got a dick on him
i go i go brian is the baby okay because
i knew he's coming around the time he
sends a picture he's like yeah kid's
fine big dick i'm like all right dude
all right man okay
most dads say that but he does have a
hobby one better because i have a hug
better the gyno
all the doctors so when the baby's born
and it's premature like that you get the
everybody comes in to make sure like so
you have the pediatricians that come in
they're doing [ __ ] you don't even know
right yeah yeah cedar sinai is
incredible yeah
navy seal [ __ ] so they all come in
i mean
navy seal [ __ ] cause they delivered your
baby
yeah it's gone on
i mean both my kids yeah i mean
navy
[ __ ] let them have a dog all right so
don't wait navy seals deliberately never
love my story
don't
so
so but they take the kid out and they
put him under the lamp right
and i look at his dick and i'm like
that's a dick dude yeah and so i go in
front of everybody there are probably 12
people in the room and i say and i go
don't say it brian don't say it but i go
i gotta just say and i was like what i
go is it me or does he you got a chat
the kid's gotta get a hold of the kid's
got a piece on it that's what i said i
go the kid's got a piece on him and the
my guy was with the ob gyn who delivered
the baby she goes every guy that's what
they always say every time they're born
that's the first thing you're expecting
a little thing and she said but i will
admit i will admit it
and i was like i [ __ ] won damn well
yeah we just gotta hope it continue you
know because sometimes yeah you know
well yeah sometimes what you want to
keep growing with the body like you
don't want that to like you know yeah
yeah well that's right well thanks for
the downer on that i know i was like
oh he was five pounds seven ounces
little dude little guy little red guy
yeah a little teriyan with a big dick
that's right well like that now here's
the thing he comes out what's funny
about this is that when they they give
you an epidural sometimes the baby's
heart starts to all of a sudden
they start twisting her around they
can't find it yeah and then what happens
is out of nowhere you don't realize
there are 15 people monitoring like
something happens well they all come
running in
and then they're just like doing stuff
and i'm like what the [ __ ] then they got
they wheeler into another room they
might do a c-section then the heartbeat
comes back did they do a c-section no
because then when the baby was coming
then when the baby's coming out they
couldn't find the heart beat
and that happened sometimes and then
they she just okay this baby has to come
out now and they're doing this black
hawk down pulling [ __ ] open and getting
it ready she puts a suction thing on the
head hedge because this is going to be
it was so [ __ ] crazy and then the
hard part comes back and comes out then
then they take the baby then we have the
baby and then you're like you're going
okay we're asleep with the baby and then
the nurse goes you know i don't like the
way the kid's breathing huh
we're just going to go check it out boom
i see you nicu put him in the little
yeah yeah now he's got to have oxygen
you know and you're staring through him
through a [ __ ] glass oh yeah and then
it's like well
we're going to take him home today you
know he's got some jaundice we got to
get him under a little bit [ __ ]
babies when they're little like that
that's why you said navy seal [ __ ] well
well i'm still oh yeah here's what's
funny about that
you got 12 people where they might have
to cut her open in three minutes they
have to get a baby out in three minutes
right otherwise
the longer the baby's heartbeat or less
oxygen you know yeah what i thought was
interesting about it was that they they
i i just know something's wrong right
away because 12 people come in without
exaggeration 12 people and i'm like what
the [ __ ] is this and they're they're
grabbing her and they're moving and and
uh the doctor they always have a doctor
come over to the father and he sits down
and he goes so here's what's going on
not a big deal
and everything else and then when the
baby's coming out
they always have somebody next to you
you they have you holding they don't
want you standing alone in the corner a
lot of times they'll have you holding a
leg or being there and they always have
somebody next to you and and you know
why that is because you might faint and
they're they're watching for you
everybody's everybody's watching all
this stuff no one was around me when it
happened no
they're probably too big you know what
you know what it is [ __ ]
[ __ ] no not me that's what i said about
you you were good i said to my girl i
don't get squeamish about this stuff
there's nothing that no there's no
chance i'm fainting yeah i'm way too
much
i'd be curious what the odds are how
many dads are fainting i think they just
got to cover their ass but i bet it's
not that no it's never that high but
everything there is also that ground is
[ __ ] hard and cold that's what i mean
like
like it's all about life so [ __ ] cold
and just savage it's it is called
they're sad i don't hate them i walk
through it but also even cedar is a
great hospital it's like bro can you not
create better food well dude like do you
have to keep saying that [ __ ] oh my god
where's the worst food in the world
beverly hills like do you do you have to
serve
food how hard is it
it's literally prison like ciao i ate
lasagna i'm still digesting it
it's just the worst food in the world
man i don't get it yeah even at that
hospital it's a nice hospital yeah it's
just the worst because a lot of dads cry
which i get i understand that crying is
fine no i don't have any problem with it
i i mean i'm i was so focused on you
because i was worried about other stuff
so yeah yeah it's it's like i've also
done it two other times before yeah yeah
third yeah you got this triple yeah you
rolled up and then you and then you were
able to not only be around the baby and
then you came to uh
you and i featured for dalia's first
weekend back yeah levity live about him
how about he crushing how how how
it was so amazing man and they loved
they went crazy when they were yeah
i did sunday with them
i i was going why are you doing sundays
dude what are you doing i mean sunday
was like it was a saturday sure it was
insane well tomorrow because today's a
holiday yeah oh that's right that makes
sense you're racist but yeah
right i didn't know it was well because
you're right there's so many holidays
does columbus still get a day or they
nix that
i think it's called
columbus
uh i called i texted the chain here and
i said can we do the foot race at noon i
was all ready
and then i get i get from brendan and
chappelle i get well i didn't i didn't
bring any gear i was already over here i
don't have my shorts on my shirt i've
been here since 8 30. i can't run in
these animal packs i just can't these
are the ones we'll do the damn race okay
yeah you're like done well i know right
i always wanted to do it
you're not involved i said why don't we
warm up well daddy ran last night and
how was it watching you ready for the
tough mudder i couldn't work you know
what the thick mutter is next saturday
no it's not yes here's the [ __ ] am i
gonna do here's what i'm gonna say i
will i i will not be able to run a
stride before then i'm gonna take some
anti-inflammatories and i'm gonna do
this [ __ ] race yeah and then i'll
have some trouble walking for the next
one what's what's i got bad but even me
like after that tough mudder you know
because it's rare you go that long and
go all through those obstacles like i
was sore as [ __ ] i'm getting
it's such a fun time oh yeah i can't
wait but i i'm definitely i'm going to
be trying i'm going to be in trouble i
just really hey do we have to [ __ ]
swim a lake
no
okay do you run heel to toe or do you
write i just go
i just
do you run i don't know come on what i
do i [ __ ] lace up my kicks and i [ __ ]
but do you run yeah yeah heal the torah
or do you
are you mid-foot guy i don't know think
about it i don't run on my toes no no
yeah i don't think you want to run on
your toes like that not that long but
midfield i don't know how the [ __ ] i
don't know it doesn't matter
no matter you need to get better inserts
i think that's what and when i saw you
when i was in my car i was on the phone
i saw you walking up barefoot there
couldn't be so when you wake up in the
morning i'm sue you get out of bed and
you're barefoot i can't walk
no there's nothing worse than
walking barefoot on a flat surface for
your planter okay that's the worst thing
you can do okay so have you should get
out of bed and stretch it there's have
they showed you stretches no
i'll show you the stretches i need them
there's one that's like life-changing
really yeah but you you shouldn't get up
and just start walking
i couldn't walk yeah and then you
walking outside there barefoot you can
make it ten times because i had i had
flip-flops on what were you walking up
don't wear flip-flops for so many
reasons but really for your planner
definitely not flip-flops okay because
it's making your feet work even more
which gives even more inflammation okay
so
get rid of the sandals all right for
multiple reasons but really for your
planner you know but you know remember
talking about lazy people but you know
so your feet are working so it's going
to make it worse but also just because
you want to be respected in life you
know you feel me
so it works planners actually help in
multiple ways dude you wearing open-toed
sandals don't wear those with jeans all
right and i go you surfing all right
are you unless you're kelly slater
i [ __ ] with your style all the way but
when you come like when it comes to like
open-toed sandals i'm like when people
wear sandals on a plane i'm like you
just have your toenails well my favorite
my favorite people like i'm eating a
[ __ ] sandwich dude sometimes you see
a rookie who comes on a plane and
they're in a tank top and shorts and
they think it's freezing
no matter where you're going freezing oh
we were on a we're on a cross-country
flight there and this woman was in front
of me i felt so bad and i could see her
and she was going like this and she
looked at finance
i'm just freezing and i and i i was like
you know and i had this
really nice toasty warm patagonia thing
and i just went
and i go would you like this and she
goes
no i i mean if you're not using yes you
take it because you know what this is
there's nothing there's nothing you can
do either like go tell the pilot turn
down they see shut up [ __ ]
like you're you're gonna be cold you're
gonna be terrible at the hoodie minimum
i don't care where you're going [ __ ] you
i'm from l.a to florida in the middle of
summer
correct no matter what correct cause you
have just
yeah what are you crazy no no
i got a t are you out of your mind you
see dudes with tank tops they're jacked
they're like this is my chance to show
people my arms okay on a flight yeah
choose your alarming yeah you have a
good time with that so y'all did both
nights i did friday saturday brian just
did i had to only do one because you
know yeah the baby yeah they'll throw up
and he did just early saturday
oh okay i brought my daughter oh you did
oh that's nice
have you bought shows
uh
air juan a few months ago but she was
sitting down
when you brought her in i
you know i was i thought it was a chick
i was like hey what the [ __ ] i was like
it's
stella that's my 13 year old i've
noticed since she was like this yeah
yeah it's insane isn't that crazy what
what she's and then she goes i once saw
something sauce do stand up she's like
well i went to my dad's special in
chicago she's like and then when you
performed my mom covered my mind she
loved your stats
she liked it oh yeah she thought she she
was laughing so funny and she but
apparently because i did i did like
basically i tailored my set to her right
oh she kept shouting out yeah she loved
that it was about my kids and i did an
animal stuff i just i can't do you know
so uh but i guess she was laughing her
ass off and it was really great she like
they told me that she was yeah she was
so excited and she you know it was like
a big deal for her because
especially to be under 21 getting the
comedy club
that i mean you know some of that some
of that comedy was chris i love what
chris is doing his new stuff is
fantastic he's really grown up oh yeah
when when a boy came out a man yeah
really yeah yeah winning a boy came out
of man that's that's why i attacked him
i was like you know obviously it's
terrible yet to deal with but you know i
think as far as your career goes like
i hate that this was what made you
change of course correct
a very harsh correction yes yep somewhat
real [ __ ] i think all of us are gonna
you know one of the things i as i get
older i realize that nobody escapes
course correction and nobody escapes
chaos i don't care who the [ __ ] right
there and i hope the people i love don't
go through chaos that you can't walk
away from sometimes you have chaos that
that comes in a way that you know the
the frustrating thing about being a
human being is that we are easy to [ __ ]
up and destroy and you know you can work
your whole life for something and it can
be taken away from you that quickly we
know this we know this but it doesn't
mean that you don't get something in
return
yeah you know that's what there's
something to be learned if you're open
if you're open
you're going to learn that if you're
open yeah yeah a lot of people let it
destroy you turn them bitter and all
that
the funny thing about like what i what i
find the challenges are not what you
think they're going to be so you think
when you go through some [ __ ] right that
you're going to be whatever it might be
losing all your money you know somebody
your wife takes your kids from you
whatever it might be you know
you you think that the challenge is i
got to just buckle down and and readjust
and that actually isn't what it is a lot
of times what happens is it [ __ ] up
your contract with life and it can make
you bitter and it can make you angry and
it can make you all these things and
that'll change you yeah that
fundamentally changes you so
a lot of times forgiveness and keeping
your heart open and staying joyful is is
i'm a hallmark guard it really is it
really is though i mean i know i i get
what you're saying live laugh
in a way in a way you love left left it
was like that tyson thing that said no
stop you can't let that the devil wins
if you [ __ ] like if the guy [ __ ] you
over and you and you change
he changed you he has power over yeah
that's a [ __ ] weird thing to think
about
how was arizona it was good yeah when i
went out there to visit my mom she
recently had surgery and stuff and then
uh trevor wallace happened to be out
there doing shows and standing up live
and uh man he sold out that four shows
at that [ __ ] that's dope beast
yeah it was it was awesome it was really
cool and a lot obviously a lot of
fighter in the kid fans in the audience
and stuff i didn't i didn't know you
also went back home that was like the
anniversary of your brother passed away
no it was anniversary it was his
birthday oh gotcha yeah it was his
birthday
so yeah i went out there as well you
know because my mom had the surgery and
just to be an adoptive mom or real mama
my real mom yeah real mom someone
visited a real mom and then she gets
real sad around that time so i just like
to be with her yeah yeah how
how long ago it was 2013 when he passed
i think
i was 26 he was 28. and how's your mom
how's your how's your mama doing she's
doing good i mean she's just living as
best she can you know like are you guys
close
now we never were like you know
when i was going through that [ __ ] with
uh my stepfather you know my mom
i was so flip-flopped like 50-50 with
her right because i ate your mom yeah
and you know because i was like man she
was always nice to me she was never mean
to me
you know but she was with this dude that
was a piece of [ __ ] you know that
treated me like [ __ ] and i guess my
thing was
like
what
and i didn't realize this until after my
brother had died that she was going
through the same [ __ ] mm-hmm and you
know so did you talk to your mom get her
perspective like why are you with this
oh i mean you when that's so my
stepfather had kicked me out of the
house like literally put all my [ __ ] in
trash bags really did your favorite yeah
oh did it be a solid i was doing
backflips outside i was like damn good
walking down the street with trash bags
and [ __ ] yeah but uh uh
you know
but and i actually saw him
i saw my stepfather yeah did you punch
him in the dick or what no i don't want
to hit him at all no i would no no yeah
that's that's not how i want to act but
uh friendly
yeah
yeah how how how he's he has to be kind
of you know he has to be kind of
embarrassed right he's terrified of me
yes and i and you know and i actually
don't like that yeah i don't like that
easy but how did you lose your anger how
did you lose your how did you [ __ ]
deal with all that [ __ ] well i i've had
three different anger management
teachers i had to go through i started
anger management in high school so what
do you do when you get angry or whatever
do you look at it do you separate it do
you watch it or something i mean now
sure journal journal like no other yeah
you're not on the road nonstop non-stop
you'll see me up early in the morning
just journaling
um but i mean
you know like yeah i guess the biggest
thing you know
i don't know yeah
that's i don't know i don't like that
he's intimidated by me i don't like that
he's like scared of me because i'm like
that's not what i want his own
insecurities is he knows what he puts
his throat and then you've still won
yeah it makes him feel tough yeah yeah
yeah and only reason why i saw him
because uh i have a brother my youngest
brother
uh special needs and so like whenever
anything
you know they he needs anything you know
that's when he'll come around or
whatever so i saw him and he like it's
like weird man because he's like you
know hey chappelle like he's like he
can't even look me in the eye he's
embarrassed yeah and i'm like
you don't you don't have to you know
like like it's it's all like i'm good
i'm fine you know what i mean like i'm
i'm not
i don't know i just don't want that to
be the the thing i'd rather just be how
do you know i don't know if you're ever
going to fix that yeah
you know
exactly and you know i'm not i don't
feel like i should have to nor do you
know what i mean or need to it's on him
it's on him yeah you know big time yeah
that that's a lot cause you've done that
yeah i've done the work he has you know
what i mean and i well he feels guilty
right or he knows he was wrong
guilt is [ __ ] heavy because he's like
he goes i took my [ __ ] out on this dude
and i had no reason to do so
that's you know that's the one thing i'm
so glad that i don't have is like
regret on that level some people [ __ ] up
so badly that they have regr like like
you can do you can commit sins yeah and
and you can't touch kids you can't live
it down yeah
right you got [ __ ] that you can't live
down like i don't thank god thank god
that's well and then there was things i
realized about him like
his father
just left him you know he was never
there
so and for the longest time he thought
he was a great father to me because he
was there but that was just all he knew
that's his perspective he goes my father
wasn't around i'm in his life
you know what i mean so like that's what
he thought oh yeah you know and also he
wasn't he wasn't treated the best like
he was beat pretty bad too correct so it
was like this he wasn't getting any
props for being better than his dad in
his mind probably exactly he thought he
was he literally thought he knows he
literally thought he was doing his best
yeah you know life is one continuous
mistake do you i thought i was gonna
text the group chat about it but it was
super heavy and uh cheerleading because
cheer season two came out yeah
you saw you watch it yeah i'm on the uh
eighth episode right now i was texting
chappelle about so yesterday so that
school i showed you where i was
competing yeah that's that's my school
oh really yeah trinity valley no they're
bees yeah yeah trinity valley dude
that's my boy
i [ __ ] knew it yeah i forgot you
because they tell his story i'm like is
this guy chappelle
i'm like it's [ __ ] chappelle really
yeah because that was the story about
how
one year i was like this is no it's
chappelle because they talk about them
because yeah again obviously we make
jokes about there's a lot of gay guys in
church then they go to him he's like
from the hood yeah and then he uh he was
playing football like all i care about
was football he's a big sports head yeah
he's in this well he's playing football
yeah and then a cheerleading coach they
saw him do something she was like you
should come out for the children he's a
beast he's like that shit's weak man oh
he's on the national team like he
represents the usa yeah he competed for
like team usa yeah he's a monster a big
thing but i was like is this guy
chappelle yeah he's right
the straight guy yeah yeah
but what's great did you get to episode
six yeah so i watched the first two
they're famous now which i don't i was
like i don't really like this show
anymore yeah i was like i just want to
see the jerry episode so episode six
called jerry so you know jerry was the
guy who for those of you who didn't
watch cheer there was one kid who would
have matt talk and he was america's
sweetheart everybody [ __ ] yeah
everybody everyone loved him he was big
on youtube everyone [ __ ] loves guy he
was on ellen he was correspondent for
the oscars he was on good morning
america uh regis and kel everything
everything everything and then
um in the height of his blowing up
allegations came out against him two
twin boys who were 13 when they came out
where 13 came out and
said he was like
basically like harassment
for sex stuff like that what's nuts
about this cheer doc is they have the
two
twins telling you what happened verbatim
step by step
isn't he in jail now oh love yeah
minimum 15 years the trial hasn't gone
on he's [ __ ] [ __ ] bro they they came
in like raided his house cause he
because he admitted having uh sex with a
15 year old boy and then there's like a
bunch of other cases against them but
with these 13 year olds they were two
redhead twins
and uh the kids young they're into
cheerleading yeah and so he he started
like dming him talking to him and stuff
like that and was asking for like picks
stuff like that and the kid was like i
felt pressured so i sent some pics they
started being super aggressive corn them
in the bathroom there's all this [ __ ]
yeah all the [ __ ] yeah but what's crazy
is
that the mom she the only reason she
found out is just her son was acting
different she's a really happy kid but
he's acting different after going to the
same like competition with jerry he's
acting different so she got on his phone
and then saw a video of like jerry like
jacking off she's like what the [ __ ] she
reports it to the and this is what i
would talk to you about she reports it
to the cheerleading association they do
nothing usa and there's 60 open cases
where they do nothing it's a real
prominent cheerleader yeah that's a huge
problem huge problem
it's like gymnastics too like underage
kids
so they do nothing so the mom goes cool
story goes to the fbi oh yeah the fbi
goes excuse me yeah and then really [ __ ]
around
oh they raided his house
took his phone and this kid so stupid he
cleared his phone bought a new phone
didn't think the governor would pick up
on that and start doing the same thing
texting underage kids okay yeah
but hit my whole video
i would be willing to bet
bottom dollar i guarantee it that jerry
was molested as a kid and when i see
this i i'll see what he did is [ __ ]
terrible if you know his story like i
don't know but what i was saying before
you tell me what i assumed is he he he
has a sickness yeah he's a real sickness
yeah so his story basically
um from what i learned on cheer because
i mean
uh he
his mom they were homeless they were
living on the street yeah and she was
paying for him like finding her way to
pay for him to do cheers
him and his brother i think his brother
they lived on the street for like years
yeah and eventually his mom died of
cancer so like since a kid like he
doesn't have his dad in his life
all these things like that surrounded
i'm not saying like this is okay you
know i'm not trying to like me neither
but also my argument to that story is
like when i when i was watching i looked
it up after they're like because they
think he's a threat because he keeps
doing it they're they're he can't post
bail so he's still in jail right now so
his trial comes up later this year yeah
they're still holding him yeah but they
i looked at what he's on trial for dude
there's multiple cases the minimum
sentence if he's found guilty which he
will be admitted to it is 15 years it's
minimum so i go through my head i'm like
all right let's say put this guy away
for 40 years right
did that can't be the way to treat this
like
he clearly needs rehabilitation he needs
help and has never had has never had any
guidance in his life yeah but he
obviously has a set of skills that
everybody [ __ ] with yeah i'm not
talking about cheerleading no no his
personality obviously his that's right
that's what i'm talking about like so
they had the the head cheerleading uh
coach on there she's like the next
segment of cheerleaders and uh they go
have you heard from jerry and they're
recording them when this is happening
and she everyone's crying everyone's
[ __ ] yeah yeah and she goes a lot of
people she goes yeah [ __ ] so many people
and she goes he wrote to me once he
wrote a long letter and she starts
crying and they go well what was in the
letter
she goes he was so positive and he goes
i'm going to get out here and be a
motivational coach that's my calling i'm
going to be a motivational coach tell
people you have not what to do and she
is it's heartbreaking because he doesn't
realize the severity of what he's facing
he thinks he's gonna be able to fight
his way out of this and get out and be
motivational and she goes he doesn't
realize like he's going away for a very
long time so what you were talking about
is and this is such a thing that they're
they talk about now
it looks like being a pedophile is a
compulsion right it's like um
you're attracted to children that's what
happens right
you're like you see a six-year-old an
eight-year-old a ten-year-old and you
are sexually attracted okay we know
that's that that happens we know that
that is disgusting now and i would kill
you all all of us with the promise
but here's what they're saying they're
saying
right now if you are that pedophile you
have a couple options one keep doing
that children until you get caught two
kill yourself to kill yourself right
whatever it is and a lot of a lot of the
and then if you're kind of a really also
coupled with a very lot of them feel
really guilty about it so they do
whatever they can but then it rears its
head and then they they have a
compulsion like gambling or something
or some some are just [ __ ] scumbags
and put themselves in positions where
they can do it and not get trump so they
would join the priesthood and get put
out or gymnastics or church whatever and
they'd go out there and they'd be they'd
be now they're they're in a parish in
the philippines or somewhere that
doesn't and
then how do they go and how is it fair
for them when they go to prison they're
the first ones that get taken back
the larger question is this it's not
that like like i okay you're a pedophile
if you said we got to kill everybody
it's i'm not going to lose that much
sleep over it yeah i want you to kill
them first okay but but we also don't
want these people touching children
right now as it stands if you have this
compulsion you have nowhere to go if you
tell a psychologist they have to tell
the police to go to jail so you have
nowhere to go you have no one to talk to
and there's a movement that says if this
is a sickness if this is a compulsion if
these people don't have anywhere to go
where they can talk about this thing
without going to jail
then what then the alternative is they
keep doing it until they [ __ ] get and
you got 50 kids and it's on the dark web
and it's a bigger yeah exactly then you
have exactly even big business guys are
involved right now
what do you do about people you do is
instead of defunding police you put the
money into prisons to actually
rehabilitate you're making sense now you
mean you should have you should have any
resources so
we complain about how many people they
put away in prison well what if they
actually were better
civilians when they got out after
serving their time yeah oh my god well
do you not realize that's what it was
for me until it became a business that
would be one thing but also there's
there's they're short-handed in all the
child pornography that's on the dark web
yeah that [ __ ] they don't we don't have
enough of a task force i'm telling you
we don't but again i'm not conspiracy
guy but when that giselle maxwell
whatever yeah do you not notice how many
child sex rings are getting taken down
lately you think that's just a
coincidence yeah part of her you know
deal i didn't know that there's a bunch
getting [ __ ] taken down like this
right now a real big one in florida got
thickened up really yeah that comes from
her man really yeah that's the fed's
getting it and [ __ ] shut why did she
so she knew about all these secrets yeah
she's in on it she knows who's in it
who's that is that true oh yeah yeah and
they're not releasing the name i didn't
know on the book if you notice a lot of
like they have that black jerry up signs
black book all the there's like names
that you kind of know and then a ton of
names are blacked out they think why are
they blacked out
they think
they think it's because a lot of those
names are still involved in politics or
have power right now i bet that's what's
scary well look at prince andrew he had
he literally was he had all his military
titles stripped and he's basically out
of the royal family that's the queen
they're still coming for him too that's
the queen's hold up
if you know anything about the royal
family her son it's her favorite son
that's her pride and joy
have you ever seen pictures of him when
he was younger do you ever see how
handsome that guy was when he was
younger he always looked like [ __ ] no
prince handled look at him right there
no no
no no no absolutely not stud click on
click on that one the one that got him
[ __ ] no no
our definition of stud is completely
different uh bad picture that's him
how dare you
what a strange thing man they would go
out to uh
island and it'd be all these girls
all right kiddos ufc 270 is here in
draftkings sportsbook the official
official sports betting partner ufc they
have one hell of a heavyweight offer for
you this weekend all right and they have
the special odds boost for all the tfat
k listeners and viewers all right so the
fighters this week my fighters are
vieira brian moreno and francis zagano
all you do is go to the draftkings
website click on the boost your odds you
see my name brendan shobb there and it's
a parlay so all three have to win
francis vieira brian moreno they all win
we're all making bank for ufc 270.
all right just head to the app right now
find brenton shops picked under the odds
boost tab doesn't matter if you're new
or existing customer bet on it get your
boosted odds and ride along with your
thick friend all new users download the
top rated draftking sportsbook app now
use the promo code fighter when you sign
up bet on my parlay fires to win
saturday night for ufc 270 and take
advantage of my special odds boost
that's promo code fighter only at
draftking sportsbook the official
sportsman partner of the ufc must be 21
or older new jersey pennsylvania india
michigan virginia only restrictions
applies to draftkings.com sportsbook for
details gambling problem cool call 1-800
gambler or in virginia 888-532-3500
hey guys can i talk to you about uh
something important yeah
look
there's a company called ballsy now let
me finish okay see you take care you
take care of your face right you keep it
trimmed like you know hydrated but you
can't just let things go crazy
downstairs you got a garden and the
problem is they get irritated there's
all kinds of shitty stuff that goes on
down dude i wish it was like a quality
long-lasting product that's formulated
to keep me fresh comfortable and
confident you really do man do you want
sack spray you want sack spray you want
a ball trimmer well they got you bro
they got a sack with dude they got
essential oils and plant ball wash balls
zach spray or no sulfates no parabens no
synthetic dyes do testing on it this is
for all bros whether you're a guy who
loves lawn work and drinking a cold one
in your man cave you're interested in
self-care but don't want to smell like
cupcakes or flower arrangements ballsy
is for all guys who want a great product
to solve your ball deeds we still got
the backpack get the sack package
right now
well then we gotta get to the sack
package all you gotta do is
products and nobody knows your sac bet
on you that's why you take a little
short quiz and they customize
it your personal sack you get you get a
sack pack that's customized to your sack
what kind of a quiz is that i gotta take
this quiz dude you gotta do it man and
listen we've tried it and my sack is so
freaking happy man so keep the funk off
your junk right now if you go to
ballwash.com and put in promo code
fighter20 you'll receive 20 off that
swimsuff plus free shipping when you go
to
paulwash.com put the promo code fighter
20 ball wash ballwash.com i want to say
that all the time now ball wash
how old was that girl she was like 17 or
something yep the rehabilitation
uh
from when my dad got out you know how
hard it was for him to like not come
back to it tried to do well he could he
couldn't it almost he had to he kind of
had to because like there was nothing
he couldn't make money instantly he
could wait he couldn't make money
because what job can't get if you have a
felony on you yeah and he wanted to he
was trying to be mine in my brother's
life or whatever but he couldn't because
he was just like
because i i'm trying to like go straight
i'm trying to do right but he goes i
[ __ ] i [ __ ] can't so he went back
to drug dealing then went back again
[ __ ] so it's like it's like it was
easier for him to get back and then for
him to stay out yeah and and also they
know the game and that's how they make
money he said that he said that second
sentence he did was like the worst one
oh because he knew what he signed up for
yeah because and they knew him they know
his rap they know his rap sheet
so they were like they were [ __ ] with
him like and he was he was doing a
shorter shorter sentence so originally
he went in for
he got uh life for attempted murder
and then he felt that he that wasn't
right or whatever he didn't do it yeah
uh who was my dad uh
he didn't he find like uh he studied law
he stayed laughing he studied law in
prison
and basically uh
realized that the system had [ __ ] up
and i guess when when you sign someone
off for life i think there's a specific
person that has to sign that paper and
she didn't sign it and they didn't sign
that paper and so my dad caught that and
i think
not only did he get released but i think
a bunch of other inmates on that got
released it's like you could search like
kevin mcdonald versus the state of
arizona i don't know something like it
but but it's you can like yeah he found
a loophole and got out yeah he found a
little sexy
second time yeah yeah i know yeah oh bro
i think you would learn he has this
crazy story i don't know if he wants me
to tell it but
i think i want to say the day he found
out he was getting out is when the twin
towers had dropped
terrible day to get out yeah
he's like man
this place
place is more depressing than [ __ ]
prisons
that's yeah that's my dad
i remember i had a girlfriend i don't
know what any of that means but i i
remember having a girlfriend after 9 11
um when they they were talking about we
were on defcon 5 or something and then
they we're talking about a possible
chemical weapons attack or something
yeah yeah yep and so
she calls me up and she's crying and i
go what's wrong she goes i can't get i
don't have enough tape
to tape my
she was trying to put plastic around her
windows
you know me you know me
i started laughing i was like i was so
insensitive like a sweetheart and it's
not gonna that's not gonna help you and
we're not gonna die of chemicals but
also if we were that tape's to do
nothing yeah what was that going to do
she wanted me to come over and i was
like i don't know how to do that and
also i don't think you have to worry
anyways yeah and he uh he almost didn't
get out because
all right basically this dude
so like in prison like you don't really
[ __ ] with like the older dudes you kind
of just like leave them alone like the
old-timers
yeah yeah it's just kind of just been
there you know and they're just you know
they're trying to have their time get
out and i guess uh this dude
had uh slapped an old timer right
and my dad hated when
people would bully other people yeah
hated it yeah and he heard what happened
and uh basically him and his dudes
[ __ ] that dude up [ __ ] this dude up and
then my dad got put in a hole or
whatever
yeah obviously i love you this is when
he was about to get out i love you guys
[ __ ] and you know and it extended this
time
well
the dude was like yo
uh he was like beaver that's my dad's
nickname or whatever he goes he goes yo
he goes call off your goons he goes i i
won't say you you know you beat me up or
whatever he goes he goes just just call
of your goons and then because cause it
because if like if yeah i guess if you
know some [ __ ] would have went down
you know
the goons would have got that yeah dude
the goons yeah the goose is a scary name
yeah he was like dude
if you're goose he was nervous walking
around he was like [ __ ] like he goes out
like call the goons man just call him
off please and then and then uh and then
literally my dad got out of the hole and
they were like yup he won't he won't say
it was you
then my dad damn that was able to get
out the goons yeah because my dad was
ruthless in there he had to be you gotta
be i like the i mean he's got like even
nice guys you know easiest stories a
dude said what's up to him and my dad
was like you can't say what's up to me
and then then my dad and his dude get in
the fight my dad gets stabbed in the
stomach and then he had to get like
surgery or whatever yeah he's in
handcuffs bleeding get me on the [ __ ]
operating table give me an operating
table he's got this massive scar
from to this day to this day like it's
huge
i told you when i went to the miami dade
county jail you did oh yeah
get there day one i get there guy was
stabbed 12 times and and going i'm gonna
let him know just [ __ ] huge built
like a [ __ ] bridge i'm gonna let him
know [ __ ] up like that and his girl
this is the [ __ ] craziest story his
girl for whatever reason was there makes
no sense if you think about it he's got
he's all patched up and he's still going
and his girl i remember this girl trying
to keep him calm before they were going
to take him to you know the infirmary
and then i saw the dude nope she was
just maybe she was there visiting it
made no sense she's dropping off there
supplies yeah she was there right with
him she goes i'll do anything for you
you know i i got you i'll do anything
for you and he was [ __ ] shouting
because the dude who did it was right
there and i went and saw that guy just
had a towel on the [ __ ] jacked and
stuff i mean horrible
horrible [ __ ] man just shanked
really [ __ ] yeah like a little thing
my dad has a real crazy i'll tell you oh
by the way real quick that was the first
time i got what's called psoriasis
you're stressed out stressed
oh because i went because i they took me
took me for a tour and i went up to the
uh where they keep crazy people so there
was a guy with molested children and he
was crazy he was talking to himself well
we don't really have facilities for the
mentally ill at least not when i was
there in 19 whatever 2000 whatever so
they they take you
and they put you in a glass aquarium
it's a glass aquarium and somebody sits
in a steel chair and watches you 24
hours a day so you're on suicide watch
and you're in a glass aquarium and
there's a there's a there's a metal cot
and you're put in a
well it's like this see this cup
it's an orange nylon poncho see my my
struggle with this is if you touch kids
that's what you get [ __ ] oh no it's not
just that it's also just crazies yeah
and so so then so then they're sitting
there and so i go in there and i see
this and i don't like i don't like this
and the the the guard you know i'm macho
guy right the guard sees my face because
i'm having a meltdown i'm i'm [ __ ]
dude i'm about to have a meltdown like i
thought i thought i was going to start
crying because i didn't know what to do
with this situation i didn't know what
to do with this
i felt so bad about everything about
life i was like this is the worst [ __ ]
it was the worst place in the world
and the guy and the [ __ ] guy who runs
it goes hey he goes what'd you bring him
up here for i've never never forgot this
he goes he's a civilian you can't do
this without giving him telling him what
to expect you can't just bring him in
here like this he got mad at you but if
they told you
yeah yeah they bring out
that night [ __ ] that night psoriasis
i got i was first time i ever developed
i developed psoriasis i had huge red
splotches
the [ __ ] out i was that i was that
[ __ ] up over it uh [ __ ] jail but my
dad was telling me the story so i guess
arizona
neo-nazi or whatever
white power dude
yeah aryan brotherhood didn't get along
with aryan brotherhood in like
california
so this dude comes in
uh
from california and he's like talking
[ __ ] to like those the arizona
neo-nazis or whatever right and this
dude's cell was next to my dad's cell
and there was this new guy that came
into prison and he wanted protection
right and they were like okay if you
want protection you got to handle that
dude you know the dude that's talking
[ __ ] the california neo-nazi right
so i guess one day
the dude was like uh
mopping
outside the cells outside of that dude
cell and like my dad's cell right and
when the coast was clear he had a knife
like shank that was under this like mop
and i guess he like [ __ ] went in and
just
gets this guy hits him up
my dad said that body sat there for
hours until someone came until someone
came jesus and then he said blood
started like sneaking into so much blood
stepping into his cell god damn he said
like that's how [ __ ] that was meanwhile
he's like trying to like
that that's what made my dad like
you know one of the many of things that
happened
he was like i gotta get the [ __ ] out of
jesus christ it was like that [ __ ]
like and but that's what he saw like
every
day was [ __ ] like that right it's been a
dark podcast yeah yeah
it is it's a dark one and i got
psoriasis yeah you got some rices
you held down c block wood or something
i got i got in fights dude i got like i
got caught out in the yard and this is a
true story and that's overall yeah they
surrounded me and i looked at him like
this and i was fighting back then you
know i was a full contact fighter and i
looked at him and i go i go
you guys want to
dance
and then i read them up and then i let
him the [ __ ] up
how was home
oh home was good i
visited my little brother just hung out
with me is it locked down up there still
or no
to a certain extent i mean everyone's
still very careful up in the bay but
then
there's also a good amount of people
still going about their lives it's just
like math it's not it's better than like
say a year ago two years ago oh yeah so
much i'm in sacramento in february yeah
you'll be fine yeah it'll be fine
nothing crazy um were you worried about
omicron
no i'm worried about people [ __ ]
worried about it yeah you know where i
stand on it i think more and more people
are like um there's nobody's been dead
yet nobody's died from no i i know it's
getting i know it's getting better
because even on cnn
you know they're like don't let your
guard down yet because everyone's like
shut up okay
shut up
even democrats like shut up shut the
[ __ ] in january
everyone's sick of it yeah they just the
new york times is like that the risks
are still there like
no they're trying it's not you know how
many people have died of mammogram how
many zero
for real yeah i was amazed that's what
that's the last that i saw
did you go to jt's wings at all no i
didn't i didn't get a jt i'm sorry
how far is jt's from tucson if we play
that's a stretch what's a stretch uh
hour and forty five i will drive an hour
and forty five yeah you will get the
phone these are the best wings i've ever
heard you always say that and it drives
me up a [ __ ] wall people it's a great
place
barbecue what do you mean it was [ __ ]
fire why why was it we got so many how
many we got like 80 wings though
that's good the way they prepare the
flavor they put them in the flavor then
they uh they they deep fry them then
they grill them with the sauce yeah
they're so nice man it's really nice
they're so nice when you bite into that
[ __ ]
that should never should nice how many
will you eat
i mean i'm just dying
i know right yeah
i've had anything but [ __ ] red meat
for two weeks i did notice that your
face looks different yeah can i
yeah so my energy's great everything
yeah yeah it's a good thing to reset
right just just yeah i don't know how
long i can stay in it i was talking
rogan this morning about and he's like
yeah i i do fruit uh it helps me with
diarrhea i'm like dude you keep saying
diarrhea i don't have any of that i
don't think a guy really you gotta get
checked out dude i don't have any
diarrhea well you should get a
colonoscopy i'm i'm fine but he has
diarrhea he says the fruit helps with
the diarrhea i'm like i mean i said this
to china i eat like a big cat at the zoo
just red meat no
no no fruit not so that's it so what'd
you have have you eaten for breakfast
yeah uh yeah i had a ribeye this morning
and then i had it then i had three
pieces of flank steak
you feel pretty good i feel great never
hungry do you have any cravings
no none because my the number one thing
on my diet's right always cheese because
of sugar because my cavities no sugar
babies you'll have a little how much
sugar is a little whiskey though or a
little alcohol when you're on it oh yeah
people go what's your carnivore diet i
say red i'm gonna have a heart attack
but red meat whiskey coffee my heart
attack hands down but your boy's losing
weight do you feel good i feel great
yeah i have no issues yeah rode my bike
40 miles yesterday i have no issues yeah
i thought you sent me that picture this
tough mudder is going to be no problem
for you
it should but the tough mudder is as
tough as you want to make it yeah if you
want to [ __ ] try and compete and beat
everybody then you're going to be in
some [ __ ] but if you're just going for a
good time and experience we're going to
have fun yeah right blast your foot's
going to fall off it'll come my foot
will fall i think i'm going to take a
bunch of anti-inflammatories before 100
you should that's what i should do
another thing i i'm going to bring uh
one of my thick boy fanny packs and
stuff it with those uh
gel packs with caffeine in them because
they have electrolytes because last time
they're cramped up bad i'll have them
for all of them yeah okay good yeah i'll
bring them for all of us yeah yeah me
and jay been talking back and forth
what's you see the shoot
bro
jay's not ready for this oh no jay is
more than ready for this jay's acting
like he's [ __ ]
hiding through minefield in iraq dude he
said
i sent the group the shoes i got for uh
these nike these purple and acg nike's
that i got for the tough mudder and then
jay goes i'm all ready too dude he sent
his shoe
it's like he's running tough mudder on
the moon
waterproof
they're [ __ ] bomb proof they're
these big heavy are you met in black
honey he's got goggles he's got
compressions
oh my god i don't get mud in my eyes my
god
goggles
i should do i said you know how big of a
dork you're going to look like in that
storyline i guess the sun's heavy so you
probably bring a hat right or something
no
sure wear a hat
sunglasses if you want you might lose
them but yeah last time i ran with i
have a headband on that's it yeah so my
hair doesn't flop in my eyes i'll wear
it jay is [ __ ] like legit yeah
legitimate
picture of like all this stuff what the
[ __ ] you running a tough mudder or
[ __ ]
run on mars
it's so intense and he's like and then
uh and then he goes are my feet gonna
get wet i go 100 bank on it you know his
feet are all weird they're like frogs
and he was alright he found waterproof
socks yeah yeah you got water i go dude
your feet are only going to be wet for
two hours he goes oh i can't risk being
wet
i'm like you know what maybe this isn't
for you
goggles waterproof slugs
also i don't think he's doing a lot of
running right
no there's no way he's doing any running
are you doing any running yeah i ran
with him the other day yeah no man my
wind is fine my goddamn foot my heels my
heels just went nah so i got to figure
it out
and i'll run tonight i'm doing it though
yeah it'd be fun yeah
christian are you how are you preparing
you're young you'll be all right i know
right you don't need to [ __ ] do
anything i'm just more worried about you
in the water and drowning because yeah
yeah i'm not that strong like i can walk
you know like i can walk through it your
ass ain't walking through i can swim but
like i can
baby like maybe doggy paddle at the best
like i'm not that strong but the good
thing is you don't you're not swimming
miles you're like even blocked you're
like you're living in water for yeah 30
seconds man by the way i want that cold
plunge it'll bring these i love it yeah
i love it like they have a cold once
right after
no during the race oh during hard work
you got to get through it so how far are
you running before you hit an obstacle
course usually a mile or something or
less the first one yeah
they break it up like some it might be a
mild then obstacle some might be two
obstacles then you run half a mile then
an obstacle you know so
sometimes there's a long layoff then an
obstacle
when you get to the tail end of thing
again this i'm sure this course is
different than the first one around but
when you get to the
end of it like the three
uh last obstacles you're running for a
little bit you're running yeah or
jogging or walking whatever you want to
do i'm walking that hoe i mean last time
me mark had to run because the the the
tough mudder team was filming us
come on you guys can't walk down that's
a little [ __ ] you right yeah yeah yeah
oh but i was that's like the best but
then i was cramping up it was a
nightmare but i'm all right did you
cramp up just at the end
because i i don't eat you know and you
did you do you know that's what you
bring you eat the night you don't eat
breakfast
no but i'm gonna i'm i had a beer so
something gave me beer last time which
helps before you guys a lot of marathon
runners drink beer yep
carbs carbs
eat a bagel or some [ __ ] i won't i won't
eat a bagel i wouldn't do that no i
wouldn't i don't know yeah you're gonna
crash yeah the sugar and the dough all
that no
i'm ready those gel packs yeah
i can't wait to see which one you guys
[ __ ] out
during the race not before you're gonna
even with that like anyone like on the
fence run it okay
then walk it dude no one cares that's
what i'm saying i'm walking down there
like all right then if you have to walk
you're not walking but if you have to
walk it you can walk you know
yeah or or you can even like you can
always just cut through them like my
foot's [ __ ] up got through i mean it's
at the end you don't wait till we finish
you know wait daddy and then you'll get
your hot dog
now is it going to be a satisfactory
because you cheated and didn't finish no
no and did you deserve it absolutely not
but maybe you waste everybody's time
money and resources yes yeah but you're
still going to be i'll say i did do it
now now it's also lying now i can also
rely online nope because we'll be
filming it and i'm a show if you quit
now here's the other thing
that you're gonna have a team fake shirt
on if you don't finish i'm gonna cut the
shirt off of you now hold on on camera
yeah no no i'll fight you but no that's
fine so
mark's gonna hold you down i'm gonna cut
you am i gonna have uh am i going to
have a [ __ ] uh
thick shirt is it but is it a thick
mother shirt yeah so it's a thick mutter
so but is it a poly
does this hold to my body
it's a shirt yeah is it cotton
it's a it's a mix it's the built club
shirt all right because i want something
that just holds to my body i'm supposed
to wear tights because when i'm doing
the crawl and stuff apparently so you
wearing shorts in the tights right i
don't know i guess so i would do that i
would for you like keep your muscles
warm like that yeah i'll do that with
you all right i got to find them hoes
are you just wearing shorts
short shorts dope sneakers and a tee and
a headband
you sturdy kid
i guess man scary kid my plan let's do
it so i'm running one in january my
plans to do six in 222. that's a lot you
wanna do six one only six of them all
right the next one i'm gonna do one you
can do six with them i'll do no you can
do six of them i would do one how do
people love you yeah that's cool see me
sick yeah and then we'll line it up on
tour and like what like you were in
austin they have them in austin they
have them all over
you know how much fun we're going to
have dude
and you're getting three big balls three
big dicks
have you heard that song has anyone
heard that song anyone heard that song
put my nuts in his butt like scottie
pippen you never heard that never heard
the gay rapper no
big dick big dick you never heard this
green like spinach yeah oh yeah green
like i don't think he's amazing but
we listen to this on the road
that's the funniest it's the first song
we play when we all get in the sprinter
no it's called no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no don't put
that you're gonna get some weird [ __ ]
yeah right we'll give you the name of
the rapper yeah it's i think the song is
called three big balls i think jay
introduced us to it yeah he saw it on
tick tock and was dying
but i'm sure pretty
that's the song yeah play it
play it is it get flagged well it
probably will but you'll have to take
the take it out but
you can post the lyrics and while we
listen to it
and let me see the lyrics hold up
don't just do the lyrics
it's a great song
ooh 1.7
yes sir
big dick dick
sounds like chappelle
since july it's not like an old song big
guys and they bust on my eyes you're
disturbed christian
disturbed christianity
have you ever see have you ever heard
the thing me and rogan did that howard
stern played yeah so funny
your hat
that's our jam
that's our jam on the road i like i like
how he look i like how he uh uses
basketball player references yeah
they're clearly super into basketball
like scottie pippen yeah what else
jordan james
no it's like
it's it was yeah the joe rogan song i
think brian counter no i don't think so
hold on it's not a song it's a bit it's
a bit
it's a bit
uh
no oh my
smell at night
no
it's a it's a john yeah it's an old bit
dude we were young
on his podcast
no but the guy lex plays guitar you know
what it was i think it was on his album
never mind okay he does
so you know they'll play it sometimes on
uh
is that lex yes like friedman oh he
plays guitar he plays guitar he loves
playing guitar oh [ __ ] i didn't know
that he's that's dope special guy man
yeah though
they'll play it on uh cirrus sometimes
i've heard that bit on cirrus with rogan
so funny yeah it's you guys singing no
no we're doing a bit where he's he's
like don't be gay brother like come on
let me just let me see your ass you got
a great ass i was like she did
she says my ass is flat let me see your
ass your ass isn't flat you got a great
ass dude let me see if i can put my dick
in it for a second
and the whole time about not being gay
he's like come on let me see how i fit
my dick you just hear me going
yeah it's so funny
all right jim what do you got
all right tastes like lemon chicken
lemon pepper chicken
lemon pepper chicken so tiffany haddish
was recently arrested for a dui i guess
she was under the influence of marijuana
and she dozed off behind the wheel in
georgia she's having a hard time i think
when she broke up with comm it sounds
like she's having a hard time that and
then the bob saget thing they were
really close i love her so much i love
tiffany man dude she's so pretty in
person i've known tiffany she's gorgeous
i've known her since she was 18. her
body is ridiculous she's beautiful and
she's an awesome person and she's
[ __ ] generous as [ __ ] and she she's a
great person man all the way around
everything she's having a tough time
yeah
i hear nothing but great things about
her she's a she's been great i've known
her since she was 18 she's a great
person and uh
too too generous to to too nice to
people oh too nice yeah she had a [ __ ]
up life
yep
good person good people yeah her and bob
sager are really cool she was she was
dating common yeah yeah he broke up with
him and kind of threw some shade at it
right
uh i don't know i haven't kept up with
that one well [ __ ] what have you got too
good
so the pharma bro has been ordered by a
judge to return 64 million dollars worth
of profits that he gained from uh
changing the price of a medicine from
13.50 to what was it like 170 per pill
no i don't know 750 there we go seven
hundred and eight yeah like what
is the margin by the way that that is a
toxoplasmosis when you when you're
you're hiv positive you can get a deadly
parasite called toxoplasmosis okay and
so there's a there's this derapin which
is a drug that actually is the i think
at that time at least the only thing
that you could
use to save your life and it was 750 a
pill or it was 13.50 a pill yeah and
then
buys the company and jacks the price up
to 750 a pill
yeah so he was uh allegedly attempting
to stop the generic version the
life-saving anti-parasitic drug that he
profited from in 2015 from coming to
mark in an effort to avoid competition
basically he had a monopoly on it
does he have that money to pay back
probably somewhere he's a fraud they're
gonna get it somewhere he's a total
fraudster yeah a bad guy oh yeah
terrible little piece of [ __ ] look at
him
oh [ __ ]
that michael jackson knows
so speaking of rumors last week we had
the drake rumor with the hot sauce
that's still unconfirmed this week a
leonardo dicaprio rumor went around
where they claimed that him and his uh
girlfriend broke up and she said that
the worst date of her life was when he
rented out a movie theater played star
wars and
like ran around the movie theater
pretending to fight bad guys with a
lightsaber this went viral for about a
day and then people came out and were
like one she's never said this two
they're still together they're insane
bart's doing like sexy rich people [ __ ]
right yeah
so people are just making
young and pretty uh she is al pacino's
goddaughter
oh she is yeah i'm sure she has famous
parents i forgot who they were but
gorgeous she's gorgeous model actress
yeah that's yeah yeah
it's pretty cool to be born famous yeah
look
i like chubby leonardo dicaprio
i like him chubby he seems happier
that's why i just yeah i like jolly
chubby guys when he doesn't have a uh
he doesn't give away when he doesn't
have a role he just releases the [ __ ]
he really does
did you see his uh recent film on
netflix he's a little chubby in that oh
yeah i don't know i already killed that
roll though just look up don't look up
already kills it he's very good oh don't
look up yeah yeah very good yeah yeah i
heard jonah hill's great on there too
jonah hill kills it how is that so good
how was that movie people love it it's
like a silly kind of funny movie to
watch while you're out it's like one of
the most viewed two on netflix people
love it all the biggest celebrities are
in it too ariana grande's in it um kid
cuddies in it jennifer lawrence is in it
oh show the hill meryl streep yeah on
the beach
licorice pizza
no it looks like it's good though isn't
it it's probably like it awful it's
getting a lot of uh accolades i know
it's who's in it um everybody i know
bradley cooper's in it um
everybody wanted to follow
doctors and did bradley cooper direct it
no that's paul thomas anderson the same
guy who did there will be blood oh wow
magnolia
boogie nights now now christian love you
how old are you everyone i've talked to
has all said the same thing that it's
not good yeah it didn't do well oh
oh sean pins in it yeah i [ __ ] love
sean penn he doesn't matter either john
c reilly
well that's a 91 on rotten tomatoes
that's weird christian
no i've heard the same thing i've heard
the same thing he's saying i i haven't
no oh anthony molinari good for him i've
worked with him good guy they're so bad
you really didn't like it though i tried
so hard to
but i like i really wanted to like it
but i just couldn't yeah what's it about
um honestly it's so confusing that first
box
at first it's about like a child actor
then he opens a pin uh like he falls in
love with this uh
photographer that's taking the school
photos like he's trying to get her to go
on a date with them they become friends
then they open up a pinball business
together
a water bed built like yeah it makes
absolutely no sense
do they play pinball wizard in there by
the way i have no idea the honestly the
best part of the movie for me was
bradley cooper's part and he was in it
maybe 10 minutes and even then it made
no sense he played with barbra
streisand's uh boyfriend all right well
i won't see it yeah
see what happens
alana him appreciate that one
cooper so this is an update to the logan
paul fake pokemon cards
he
made a youtube video where he went to go
get it authenticated and the only way
for them to make sure that the cards
were real or fake was to open up the box
then losing its value if it was real
uh they opened it up and it was filled
with gi joe cards
and so he lost 3.5 million dollars and
that's how he made the youtube video
scene he then promoted his new drink
prime saying oh please buy my drink so i
can recoup this money he actually bought
the pokemon cards from a friend who had
bought it for 2.7 so the friend came out
and said i actually returned all the
money to logan paul now i'm trying to
get the money that i had spent back from
the person i bought it on ebay from
but it's a little weird because the guy
who sold it originally on ebay changed
his username three times and only had
about i think two different people
trying to buy things from him in the
past
this exact box of cards
was sold for seventy thousand dollars
prior but when the person who bid on
asked the seller to authenticate it they
pulled out so the seller on ebay had a
really shady pass of like selling
3.2 million with that shady pass so uh
yeah jake i mean logan paul has all his
money back thankfully it's just the guy
that he bought it from now his friends
kind of [ __ ] out of his money jesus
christ
[ __ ]
um that's that's crazy ain't that about
a [ __ ]
because you know mike's big into the
cards and stuff and he was saying he has
friends who
you know they'll buy a pack of like box
cards worth like a million dollars
but when you go to insure it
they don't
they don't give a [ __ ] about street
value so you're insuring for 100 bucks
even though you paid a million so
they'll drive to where it's shipping at
and wait for days for it to land so they
can grab it just because people if
people find out they're gonna steal it
it's a real hustle i didn't realize
i mean listen
logan paul got hustled out of trading
cards they had hustled from cats
where they jump on the trains when they
slow down and cut them with bowl cutters
and take everything out of the
the cargo holds oh really oh yeah i
already saw that recently yeah yeah did
it post that yeah i think yeah i think
so good stuff good stuff okay
i've been seeing more ever since mark's
car because mark was uh coast on
wednesday mark's car they jacked his
cadillac converter honestly you know uh
catalytic converter prices are number
one
it's a real it's a problem in l.a yeah
priest is number one are they taking the
catalytic converter yes the computer no
the computer yeah i'm sorry the the
converter yeah there's money in it
but it's it's all over the news now i
guess some real problem mark was
not joking oh dude he pulled up to my
house to run the other day and it
sounded like you drove
like he landed a plane or something like
he's driving a harley davidson but it's
a prius oh yeah he's driving a car
converter do for a car it it um takes
the takes the i think the lead out of
the fuel or something i think it just
doesn't uh emissions it has to do with
the missions cleans it cleans the car so
much so you can still drive it you can
still drive it you're fine okay and now
it's a carburetor a lot of people get
rid of the caloric converter for
straight pipes yeah louder and faster
supposedly
yeah but if you have prius you don't
want that yeah okay that's great that's
so funny it's just it's a big business
they're just jack
how about the fact that they just come
into homes these super wealthy homes in
beverly hills home invasion they just
plan it all out you know no there's not
too many of those but yeah i hear you
and i heard there's a whole thing going
is that all right yeah
it's all [ __ ] yeah look at the stats
i mean it definitely happens but it's
not like this you live in a big city man
yeah
well i think teams of guys hit a certain
string of houses and then it makes them
that happened years ago it was before
the pandemic my house got hit yeah it
was wild being back home because uh
arizona's such a wild wild west and uh
me and trevor we were grabbing chipotle
and this dude had recognized him he was
like yo man what's up man i get a
picture with you meanwhile the dude just
has his strap
right there right at his hip he's a nice
guy too yeah like justina but just like
you see it and you're just like i forgot
because i mean when i lived there like
it was just like used to it used to
seeing [ __ ] people it's a right to
care you can carry a gun out outside of
you
yeah wow yeah you can carry a gun yeah
you don't see it but i tell you what i
tell you one thing man i always say this
i mean listen i know it's [ __ ] crazy
but
i mean the chances of
you know someone breaking into someone's
home in arizona there's a lot of 99
chance that person is strapped yeah so
they're ready twice oh yeah you think
[ __ ] it twice 100 how about that dude in
texas taking over that synagogue
what happened oh they held them hostage
yeah they released his sister or like
his girlfriend who's on she's in prison
for life i was out of what it is yeah he
was
holding them holding them hostage in
hopes to release her his lover or sister
wow who had some ties to trying to kill
americans yeah damn
who was he was he uh
crazy uh he was from england of middle
eastern descent they're not calling it a
hate crime
uh no they are
british citizen malek
no they're not from what i hear
that's why people a lot a lot of people
are pissed about it
it's like they're
they never said that
that they never said it was a hate crime
yeah there's all that stuff you know
yeah a lot of like michael anti-semitic
that yeah yeah it's just like he's in a
synagogue and he's you know and if you
if you look up how much crime and like
this [ __ ] has been going on with
anti-semitic [ __ ] it's the numbers on
that are not so it's scary but somehow
it's it's anti-woke to say that because
then you're
then what you're doing is you're being
anti-islamic
so you wouldn't say that islamic guy
who is of middle eastern descent took
over a synagogue you wouldn't say that
because that would be
then pointing people in the direction of
thinking well there might be some
islamic but then it's okay to say when
they raided the capital on the six that
that's domestic terror of course white
domestic terrorists and that's okay well
well all of that stuff is fine but it
there's a there's a real agenda in the
mainstream media that just that when
they do that stuff they lose their they
lose their credibility yeah we all know
what it is it's all good yeah
you know yeah that's what brad was
talking about he goes call him what it
is
yeah it's like guys come on america
knows though like the news things are
like pulling the wool over at we know
what's going on most americans know what
the [ __ ] going on
what else you got too
oh actually quick story
so this friday
it was me and my girl in my house or my
new apartment
oh did you move yeah moved when like
maybe how many two why don't you tell me
maybe a month
did you move down here uh it's like a
little it's way closer to here than what
my other place but not down there it's
like a little north of santa monica
okay so not that because you know my
girl lives in orange county you we're we
work in here so i had to make like some
sort of like you can in the middle yeah
but i'm i'm it's like i say half an hour
to get here that's not yeah it's really
not interesting so you're just like
you're not over the hill no no you're
right yeah
it's it's way better dude okay yeah i
get here super fast now so
we're on the we're hearing a dog
screaming right
so we run out to the balcony
and i look over this
woman's holding a little baby like a
little black dog like this like puppy oh
no it's like a small dog okay it's like
a small dog dog and then i saw her just
go like this
bam on the ground and the dog just kept
screaming and then we were just like
stop stop what the hell are you doing
and then my girl's like don't go down
i'm like i have to go down there right
so then i ran down
and now of course i can't with the
heater you ran down no weapon or no no
it's a it's a woman yeah well some of
them are tough okay so me and my girl
got an argument about this tooth but
okay i went down and i just kept yelling
leave it alone leave alone and she kept
picking it up like this and saying weird
things oh she's out of her mind yeah but
it seems like it was her dog you know
yeah doesn't matter of course not no but
it seems like it was her dog but she was
just abusing the hell out of it like
actually throwing it against against the
door jesus christ so then i can't be
like stop don't [ __ ] hurt her and
another guy came over and my girl called
the police another guy called the police
as well and luckily the police showed up
pretty fast oh that's good yeah so then
the guy that actually stopped he's like
uh he gets his party his partner get her
they arrested that woman right away and
then i was able to get the dog into the
car do you have a dog now no
i felt so bad with brain everyone was
like they were trying to grab the dog
but then everyone's like he would try to
bite at the officers right but then i
was with the dog a little longer so he
was cool with me and let me pick him up
like that so what do they do with the
dog just put him shelter shelter yeah
shelter but the cop so
i was like thank you so much for coming
out for a call like this is you know
it's a dog call he goes no this is
probably one of the more important calls
we had today and he goes thank you for
everything you do too i'm like what he
goes
watch all your shows uh that's cool
that's super cool his name is jared the
police officer that's cool yeah so
here's the trivia question you're in
you're in los angeles yeah somebody your
dog you have your dog there a guy is
bashing your dog he's killing your dog
with a baseball bat he's hitting the dog
with a baseball bat you have a gun
you say stop he doesn't stop you say
stop again he doesn't stop i know where
you're going with this no you're saying
what happened you can't kill him killing
your dog because it's not your property
right because it's yeah yeah you always
say this here's the thing i know because
i was going to say i think you said this
before yeah you have it's so easy right
you can say he was threatening you and
you shot him of course you do i'm saying
i'm saying if you're caught doing it
though that's off it's on camera you'd
go to jail so my argument with my girl
was i said if it was a guy
i would have just rushed him yeah and
but she's like no something's gonna
happen you go to jail or whatever but i
don't think i can instinctually just see
that and not rush i also you don't want
to live in a world where something like
that's happened if that was a guy or a
guy breaking your house and it's like oh
is the make my day rule give me you're
not thinking about any of that
i've had my house work it's the last
thing of course
and trust me you'll be fine you're not
going to [ __ ] prison for the rest of
your life for killing someone breaking
your home you'll be fine yeah they kept
breaking your home [ __ ] that
that's that dude
okay on a lighter note
have you seen this michael jackson
impersonator
i actually do well against this guy
god he looks just
so it was unprovoked attack this guy
just kind of you know came at michael
jackson
oh the guy can't fight at all
oh michael jackson's laughing
oh michael jackson's laughing at him
this guy's a [ __ ] oh he does little
shits oh there you go triangle look at
this he goes his arm up no he doesn't
have it at all
[Music]
he's all laughing doing something though
they said get someone saying get him
michael
he's all yanking his hair
[Music]
that's it just choking bulldog
oh damn good
michael knows what he's doing here
[Music]
i like how he's just like at first
i wonder why that guy is [ __ ] with
him
just drunk probably yeah yeah
a huge weird [ __ ] and now you got
beat up by michael jackson
yeah
[Music]
oh he's hammered he's not doing too well
his shirt says can't fix stupid
yeah
and a big the michael jackson guy also
does like wrestling too
oh yeah i felt pro this weekend there
was a homeless dude sleeping in my
neighbor's yard and the cops where i
live don't [ __ ] around they could
descend a woman goes big woman goes
we'll be out of here in a second and i
go i go i feel bad for the guy because
she was obviously crazy and she goes she
goes
you feel bad for him and i go wait a
little out of his mind she goes oh boy
she just looked me and she looked at me
like i was a liberal i've been with her
i've been like you're the problem you're
the problem no i don't mean it that way
i'm with her i mean i wanted to go away
but just [ __ ] i just felt bad that's
all i i was embarrassed this is him
wrestling too yeah i want to be all like
wwe [ __ ]
does he dance
wait is this a new thing since that or
what no no he's
oh
oh this guy that's awesome
oh look at him
[Applause]
it's fantastic this guy's fantastic
that's why he was able to do well
because he said well dude practices with
that guy then he knows he trains yeah he
trains wrestling gosh
some of those michael jackson
impersonators he was very he was
actually very nice to that guy he [ __ ]
that dude up even way worse that's funny
man yeah
um okay i just saw this i thought it was
crazy
shout out to jeeps
look at the ledge
oh [ __ ] that's not good that water is
raging too man is that the is that that
[ __ ] river where all the crocodiles
are or
i don't think so you're talking about a
different river whatever the [ __ ] it is
that
well you're gonna run out of gas here
there you go there you go there you go
there you go
boy that could have been dicey for him
yeah hey get out of the way i know i
don't get that
a bunch of other ones have to cross over
you know
but that was terrifying that is
terrifying jesus chris what's also
what's okay
so uh
that's what they do with jeeps
it's a
jeep culture
yeah so uh what'd you say a t5k watcher
named jordan sent this
sent this thing in yeah
boy so check this out
yo
yes
i got a big [ __ ] announcement to make
this for all you nerds on the internet
nfts nfts well guess what i made a
[ __ ] nft but it's not just some
[ __ ] picture of a [ __ ] monkey in
a space suit eating mushrooms or some
[ __ ] it's my original jamaican accent
videos that's right whoever buys these
nfts will be the owner of my iconic this
is a cinematic history that moved the
whole culture forward but not only
whoever buys them will get a chance to
meet up with me in person that's right
the original white rude boy gandala
they're on cryptogram the links in my
bio you can go get them right now i mean
who wouldn't want to own a piece of this
[ __ ] history
[Music]
we got the whole night
he's funny he's great yeah i love him
he's great he's got a good goal
he said this most pivotal moment for the
tech industry since steve jobs created
the turtleneck sweater
that's great yeah he's got look at that
those fantastic tattoos he's great
i'm a fan
yep
uh the last one does that say sod money
what is that sod money gang that's a
hell of a maybe that's his label that's
a nice necklace
yeah he's uh
all right so i guess this uh pastor spit
on someone's face because this is a you
know biblical thing where jesus
created miracles would just spit or
something like that
i'll just play this i get depressed
changing something and you don't see it
clearly yet
but you
no no no don't do it
[Music]
[Applause]
all right and this is where
most people
would not face jesus anymore
what most people would do
is turn
away
all right man let's not watch this [ __ ]
this is no i don't know is it terrible
oh
what i'm telling you
is this guy's code what i'm telling you
is just as he's physically standing here
knowing what's coming
is he can ask for money god's saying can
you physically and spiritually and
emotionally
be able to stand
when getting the vision or receiving it
might get nasty does he slap him in the
face
this is where human beings embarrass me
might get nasty
you mean
god i just god might get an ass sell it
back
because the vision i'm about to give you
it might get nasty
all right dude
you can see it like hanging off his
beard oh and do you
do you hear and see the responses of the
people
i hear a [ __ ] weirdo and of course
what i'm telling you
is how you just reacted
it's how the people in your life will
react
when god is doing what it takes
i don't think god the miracle what are
you saying this man was blind
and what he was trying to do with this
man
is give him his dna
okay so he apologized
i bet listen man i went a little bit
what's going on everybody i hope you're
having an amazing monday i just wanted
to trying to save face what happened
yesterday when the spit hit the fan i
watched it back and um it was disgusting
like that was gross i want to validate
everybody's feelings um that that was a
distraction to what i was really trying
to do i was really trying to think come
alive and for people to see the story
but yesterday it got to live and i own
that and um i just want to make sure
people know that we want to help people
we want people to see jesus i don't want
your help if i get it he does seem like
a nice person and so i forgive him and i
he seems like a good person but yeah but
right at that point
you know what clumsy when you're clumsy
in life it can [ __ ] be bad yeah
yeah he does he does seem like a knife
sometimes you reach too far and you [ __ ]
up that was his little brother he was
doing it too oh it's his little brother
yeah okay either oh no that makes it a
little bit better
it does hey your girl's 16 and pregnant
dad i was gonna ask you about that
because you watched that show i don't
know her though i don't know it was like
a newer generation yeah i don't know who
jordan kashmir is i don't know yeah i
watch that show i don't know who the
[ __ ] that is
so was that a real video that kanye west
made about going trying to find his
daughter's chicago's birthday party
yeah
travis scott sent the location
he dropped the pin too
kylie opened the door oh really yeah
apparently uh security guards did not
want to let him in and then kylie had to
come to the front saying it's okay
he was distracted to pete davidson
chinese
uh i heard that yeah
kanye said something about uh yeah yeah
he throws like a he throws a jab at him
is
i mean he just says that something like
i survived that accident yeah
yeah god let me survive that crash so i
could beat pete davidson's ass or
something like that yeah
i think
to defend kim here she all she's saying
she's like him from his kids she's like
i just need a heads up man he can't just
pop up yeah like yeah and he didn't give
her heads up that's awesome oh they're
so cute their kids are so cute man
super cute
what else you got jen that was it a
daughter and a son right what's up no
they have four they're four oh not them
i didn't know that yep
super cute
yeah ridiculous
oh good girl that's a cute little cute
kid oh they're so cute man there you go
oh
she looks fantastic man yeah
super diamond piece all right is that it
that's it
all right kids another episode down i'm
a little depressed right now but why
i don't know the spitting yes the
spitting names [ __ ] me up yeah
i can't believe people it's just that
that was like one that just like got
mine really that's so troubling i get i
get i get really tired of my culture i
get tired of well that's not your fault
not your culture no but i'm older
no it's all part of the country i live
in yeah i get it
i don't like wokeness i don't like that
stuff i don't like a lot of [ __ ] i'm
depressed
i'm fine i don't know i gotta bring my
dad that doesn't that no i mean jesus
christ dude
jesus christ no it's not jesus christ it
sucks
there's a lot of you know i'm saying
that's why you need jesus i'm just not
like no
brian's not gonna let it all out
is this gonna help yeah no yeah i don't
know where you're gonna put it dude
teach this lesson to your new baby
i should see your animal
right it's normal this is good
tell your dad give me 50.
uh
one date again in la hollywood improv
almost sold out there's 30 tickets on my
birthday hollywood improv yeah callan's
birthday
performing on your b day it's shopping
friends with special guests that's
january 26 hollywood improv one night
one show only wednesday at 8pm then just
got added oh [ __ ] jay got it up there in
time atlanta georgia february 3rd to the
5th at the punch line in atlanta georgia
i haven't been in atlanta performing the
hot [ __ ] second since buckhead
theater there you go i think we did that
a long time six years uh but that
atlanta just went on sale today that's
february 3rd through the 5th and then
sacramento is february 24th through the
26th
chicago just went on sale march 24th
through the 26th but man hollywood
improv you're up on that wednesday 26
and then atl i'll be doing the dirty
bird on stage that's february third
through the fifth get your tickets now
fbtkz.com yep jamal anderson uh that's
awesome thick boy drop oh we got uh
calabasas fight campaign saturday 7 p.m
only on think boy brian callan chris lee
myself for ufc 270 cyril gone francis
nagano is on the main event on that
heavyweight championship is on the line
thick boy auto uh auto club merch drops
thursday we'll be betting on this serial
gun well i think we'll we'll be taking
some bets yeah
should we bet now or wait we'll wait
we'll wait no let's do it on the show on
saturday now now let me uh just say
where i'm gonna be here um i'm going to
be at temecula california i'm doing at
bastard's canteen january 27th it's it's
a cause comedy for the brave
and it's uh basically all proceeds go to
veterans it's being run by my buddy
scott who wrote uh a great book called
echoes in ramadi um and so i'm going to
do that and then las vegas nevada with
sam tripoli diversion amusements get
your tickets
the venue is called diversion immune
amusements go figure appleton wisconsin
skyline comedy march 3rd through the 5th
and then we'll go from there cool
and then february 25th through the 26th
i'll be in kansas city at the kansas
city kazan city comedy club then march
10th through the 12th i'll be in
springfield
missouri doing the blue room comedy club
boom
all right kids love you don't spit on
each other